[Música]
por la sol lake city o que no sea
hombres armados patrullan las calles
pero no llevan uniforme
[Música]
cada vez se ven más vigilantes
autoproclamados en las protestas contra
el racismo pero cuál es exactamente su
objetivo nos dirigimos a olimpia en el
estado de washington para reunirnos con
peter díaz fundador de american wolf un
grupo ambulante de activistas armados no
somos una milicia así pero soy
estadounidense los estadounidenses
tenemos armas me niego a quedarme de
brazos cruzados y ver como el país es
destruido y desmantelado a mi alrededor
los miembros de american wolf se llaman
a sí mismos pacificadores díaz creó el
grupo a finales de abril para combatir
las protestas antigubernamentales que
aseguraba estaban siendo lideradas por
radicales de la extrema izquierda que
eran una especie de gobierno socialista
o comunista y están tratando de cambiar
lo que es nuestro gobierno mediante la
destrucción de nuestro país viajan por
el país a menudo protagonizando en
contra protege
al punto del movimiento black lives mar
armado con lo que esos se llaman armas
defensivas es una clásica arma de
paintball en su vehículo también hay gas
pimienta un bate de béisbol y esposas
debilidad
esto sería necesario en caso de tener
que detener a alguien para prevenir la
violencia donde está la policía de algún
policía por aquí
también tienen un arma letal puse mi
mano así no es como que mi mano esté
ella sabe asista acompañamos a díaz a un
mitin proto donde encontramos otro grupo
miliciano de extrema derecha cuidando el
lugar conocido como strippers centers o
el 3% en español uno de los grupos
paramilitares más organizados de eeuu
sus miembros realizan entrenamiento de
combate en carolina del sur hablamos con
el líder de la milicia pro armas one
republic
mientras el presidente de trump culpa
los políticos demócratas por el
creciente malestar civil los vigilantes
de extrema derecha parecen estar cada
vez más dispuestos a encargarse de la
suba la violencia se está extendiendo
por el país no voy a decir que hay un
ganador
queremos la paz
pero no le tememos a la guerra
una encuesta reciente evidenció que uno
de cada tres votantes estadounidenses
pensaba que su país estaba al borde de
otra guerra civil demostramos a tres
imágenes de un tiroteo mortal realizado
por un partidario de trump de 17 años
que mató a dos manifestantes en kenosha
wisconsin en bahrein
y cualquiera que vea este vídeo
comprendió puede darse cuenta que se
trata de defensa personal
los grupos de milicias armadas no son
ilegales en estados unidos donde el
porte de armas es un derecho
constitucional
aumentan los temores de una violencia
postelectoral mientras los civiles
armados están cada vez más a la vista